is it possible
to he wants to know why a prophet said
so
Revelation and and also and what was the
other questions I don't want to miscot
you I do not I think religion is a
necessary evil
and the reason that I think that is
because the religion that the original
religion that we know of say 3,000 years
ago it is quite clear that the god in
that religion is a murderous God a
genocidal God a God that manipulate the
minds of
mankind and I don't think that I think
it is unwise to follow that are you
referring this to Christianity Today
pardon you're Afra to Judaism that is
correct the Old Testament yes yes now I
have I I I I have
spoken I have spoken with a
few I spoken with a few people who are
Islam or Muslim or whatever you call
Muslim Muslim musl Rel well I have
spoken with a few of them and the reason
why that I have never taken any interest
in it it's because my understanding is
that you you are indulge in the same you
incorpor in your religion the Abraham
Isaac Joseph all of those prophets are
incorporated into
your now in 2001 a voice said to me from
within to
read
Exodus so I've read Exodus down to
Leviticus and I became totally dis dis
disorientated there are things that I
think about that I wouldn't think
anymore because what I read was so
despicable I I I don't know how anyone
can accept it so just to so what you
just did you
utilized your experience within Old
Testament to judge all the religions
which is incorrect One Moment One Moment
it's not to judge all religion I'm not
judging any religion but you just you
said religion is evil well that's not a
that's not a judgment for me it's a fact
a judgment regardless say something is
evil or good it's a fact or not but it's
a judgment I think when people judge
make well I don't know I I don't I don't
see myself as a person that judges
anyone or anything but you just did you
judged ReliOn of to be evil well of
being that's how I perceive it to be
yeah you judge it so if you if you're
going to say kill every man every woman
every child we don't believe that by the
way I'm just saying what I read whether
I I don't believe anything that's the
first
okay iow you to speak but if you if you
listen to me carefully what I said to
you I said what you said to me in the
beginning to remind you you said you
believe or you said that religion is
necessary evil okay and you said so you
generalize every religion because you
read something in the Old Testament
which caused you to uh to be traumatized
and uh so therefore you said all the
religion is evil and that is a judgment
no doubt about that it's like someone
example of that I'm Algerian I'm from
Algeria North Africa okay imagine I go
do something evil with someone he can go
say all the algerians are evil because
CH is an Algerian and he did something
evil to me that is it's not fair for him
to do that you you see so when if you
come to Islam we have many problems with
the Old Testament for example killing
children in Islam that's not allow our
Prophet Muhammad told us in the war in
the war we're not allowed to kill
children we're not to kill we're not
allowed to kill women and we not allow
to kill a man in his Temple for example
Christian scholar Hindu scholar Jewish
scholar we not allow to go and kill him
even the Buddhist even the Buddhist even
the Buddhist the Buddhist yeah yeah any
religious person okay and even a man
without a weapon okay we're not allowed
to do that we're not even allowed to cut
off the
trees that's the teach of our Prophet
Muhammad
so so Old Testament we don't trust
everything in there because the people
that wrot the people that wrote the Old
Testament you can see they were evil
even the way they speak about God they
made God seem like a like you said evil
person evil being just kill destroy
murder you don't accept that understand
but they did that onto the args of God
they did that by God commanding them to
do that Allah already told us in Islam
I'm not talking about Al now no but I
believe Allah is the god of everyone oh
Allah is the god so we believe in the
Old Testament well well the fact remain
is that the problem that we have with
relig that I have with religion is the
coming of Jesus and John now the
teaching of Jesus and John which
contains five books in the Judaism thing
in that teaching it contradicts
everything that is said in the Old
Testament it tells you it tells you that
Jesus that Jesus tells us that the god
that the religious God of Abraham etc
etc that he was a murderer and a liar
from the beginning of time where does it
say that I'm not Christian Christianity
but respect where does it say in the New
Testament that Jesus or John said that
the God is a murderer and is a liar it
it was it said I have a problem with
that I'll explain to you what the
problem is when I was told to read that
I read everything what I read I remember
it all but the part difference is I
didn't take the verses and the thing
with me I didn't take that I just read
it and that's it doesn't say that
doesn't doesn't say that in the New
Testament doesn't not say God is a
murder of I didn't say that in the New
Testament Jesus said that in the New
Testament well it's not a new testament
really Jesus Jesus is not in the Old
Testament the
new the if you read the New Testament
what you will find is you find that the
old test that the old the original thing
is in incorporated into the New
Testament it speaks of the
same Abraham and all those prop it
speaks of that so it's not really it's
not really accurate Jesus and John
didn't come here to teach religion they
were never religious they made an
emphasis and they said we came here to
tell you the truth and said that the
truth should set you free for example he
knew they both knew that they were going
to create another religion that is
called the New Testament so what did he
do Christianity yes so what did he do he
fored us before he left he said to his
to his Apostles you must not go to the
land of Samaria you must not go to the
cities you must only go to the house of
Israel and you must not take house the
house lost of sheep of Israel and you
must not take any gifts
now how did Christianity who started
Christianity
Christian yeah PA the apostles they the
one that
started they they were Impostors and
I'll tell you why they were imposters
who who who who are imposters those who
said those who gave us Christianity
canot doubt Paul andn and they were
imposters but the fact is the fact is
that we were forn Jesus for warned about
these people false prophet and those who
will speak in the name of speak you the
word the Christ with an S pural Christ
that is why you get in today the
everyone talks about Jesus Jesus Jesus
Jesus but he forn us about that all he
they told us that he's a virgin birth
he's not a virgin birth because Jesus
Jesus himself told us on five occasions
that he is from the seed of David and
when we go to the linage of David we
have Joseph which is the father the
biological but I don't understand try to
understand where you're coming from I
mean you said you had a problem with the
religion then you start talking about
the Old Testament now you start talking
about the New Testament and it's about G
and that you remember I'm a Muslim okay
and as for there's many things you and I
will agree on meaning that for example
God telling people to kill babies and
children islamically we don't agree with
it okay so it's better of us Islamic
wouldn't do things of course Prophet
Muhammad told us clearly explicitly in
the war in the war you not allow to kill
women we not allow to kill children we
not allow to kill in Islam we are only
allowed to fight against the
combatant okay as for innocent people
even the non Muslims you allow allow it
to touch them or to harm them in thean
Allah told
usle Allah does not forbid you to deal
justly and kindly with those who never
fight you because of your religion so
Islam alhamdulillah is based upon
justice so there's no need for me and
you to discuss about the New Testament
because I'm not Christian what I want I
want to speak to you about you believe
in a Creator correct the reason the
reason why we should speak about it
Christian I'll tell you why we should
speak it because in your religion you
you have Incorporated the the
theity you have Incorporated the
prophets the prophet into your religion
yeah but the prophet My Religion we we
explain to you how the prophet
Inus we believe the way the prophets
have been portr or propagated in the New
Testament the Old Testament is the wrong
way for example David Prophet David in
the Old Testament we in the Old
Testament you that the prophet David who
a killer murderer someone who sets up
his own friend to be
for S to speak with his wife with the
wife of his friend naked I don't believe
that I don't believe David has
forication I don't believe the prophet
had a fornication with his own daughters
I don't believe that so Quran Quran the
prophets and the Messes in their best
way but you believe you believe what
what is said in your in the Quran what
what what they say that your Prophet
said but you don't believe what they say
about their prophets why is that because
like you said because when he looks at
the Old Testament the New Testament
cannot be trusted one of the things that
we have the only reason that it cannot
be trusted is because it contradicts
your teach not just about that it contct
which we know we call Universal
knowledge Universal knowledge our sound
reasoning our natural inclination now
naturally I know if someone comes to me
now and he say let's go kill a baby when
I say why you want to kill a baby for he
said ah because his father did something
to my father I know that's wrong you
know that's why Islam want the beauty of
Islam Islam goes in line with our
natural explination and our sound
reasoning because the one who gave you
that tools or those tools which is a
sound resonant and the natural
information is the same down is the same
one who sent down the Islamic Revelation
so tell me something there this innate
feeling that we have that we are created
with yes that allows us to be to use
empathy compassion to understand to be
kind to each other yes just a second
once we know that we have that with him
why can't we live that life why do just
a second why do we need religion why do
we need a contradiction of it and if you
look at it at religion what you will
find how they second our mind that when
we come here on a Sunday we see the
Christian speaking and we see the the
the Muslim and then you have this
conflict of emotion shouting and yelling
and right wrong blah blah blah I mean
Islam doesn't teach us that well well it
doesn't matter what you teach not I see
it per here but you cannot judge Islam
based upon people's action I mean I
canot judge your country based upon
people's action but to go back to your
question I'm not saying I'm saying this
is my experience here and my experience
here is I want to know is can we as
human being do you think we can
exist without the
Revelation with the knowing to hell with
the Revelation with the knowing
that we have inside of us that part of
the Supreme creator that we have within
us that part that give us the quality
question that's a good question so the
question you're asking is it not
sufficient for us to have our natural
inclination and then just live with it
no not you know why because our natural
inclination doesn't not teach us in
detail what is right what is wrong it
tell us in general for example for
example you have your wife and you have
your mother and you have your sister and
you have your daughter now your natural
explanation canot dictate to you which
one has more right over you likewise
naturally you know you should be
grateful to someone who done something
good to you the one the As for the
Creator created you naturally you said
you know what I should be grateful to my
Creator but how not according to your
feeling according to my feeling that's
why that's why based upon the wisdom of
the Creator the Creator sent the
prophets and Messengers to explain to us
in detail that which we know in general
how to live our life because our natural
ination and our sound reasoning is
limited so therefore the Revelation is
needed for us in order for us to live
and have a life which pleases the
Creator and the example are always
please is the creator yes pleas is the
creator so in other words you're saying
that the Creator needs something from us
no it doesn't need something from us and
I give you example of that well if he's
pleased if he's pleased if we have to do
things that please the sa yeah why do
you think he needs anything I'll tell
you how for example now if I saved you
imagine you're in in a house and there's
a fire in the house you know you are
surrounded with a fire you're about to
be you know you try your best to serve
yourself and you couldn't you gave up I
came and I saved your life would you
thank me for saving your life well I
would thank you of course but it's not
necessary for me to thank you I'll tell
you why it's not necessary it's not
necessary for you to thank me no it's
for saving your life he said I will
thank you would thank you is necessary
for thank you I mean like any human
beings know
that I would thank you yes but I don't
consider is necessary what I consider is
important is how you feel and you would
feel very
good and it's better it's better than
feing the Creator no no
before about the creat now any human
being with a sound resion it will tell
you it is necessary it's rather our
nature to be grateful to someone who
saved your life well if I thank you I'd
be grateful wouldn't I that's what I'm
saying but if I said but I'm saying it's
not necessary because it's like if I
give you something and I mean and I need
something in return I give it to you
free I give it to you from my heart I
don't need anything to finish I mean
like any you know why I would say to you
if you go outside the park you want to
say that you are just saying is for the
sake of arguments I respect because any
human why you think because why any
human being I've been doing this for the
last 15 years I've been speaking to
people from different background you
know and this is the first time I've
heard someone says it's not necessary
for me to thank you for saving my life
is no by necessity that if someone save
my life I'm not me out I'm not just
going to thank him I will remember him
all the time every time I remember this
man saved what saved something so dear
to me I said you know what that can Sav
my life I thank him the least I can do
is thank him least can I mean I'll be
very I say him you said you would
correct said not necessary but I said
it's not necessary and the reason a gap
here and the reason the reason why it is
not necessary because if you if you are
kind to me and done something me you
understand me I'll tell you what happens
you feel good within that's the
important thing how I feel does not
matter it's immaterial we're asking you
generally speaking if you n out of 10
people 99% of people when you ask them
Someone Saved their life they would will
tell you I will be very thankful for
that person and it's
necessary I said I said yeah we agree we
agree age but you keep saying it's not
necessary I am different am different
but I say sorry anyway if I said to you
if I said to any person don't thank me
they say no Shi you deserve to be
thanked you saved something so dear to
me even though I don't need you thank
something that's not replaceable let
alone the Creator he owns you and
everything your your own existence by
own virtue that's right you understand
so when the Creator want you to to to to
thank him and to worship him not because
a need because you are in need of
worshiping the Creator you understand I
am in need of wor worshiping the Creator
well if if I feel the need that I should
worship the Creator then I would think
that that that the Creator desire that
for me to think that yeah the Creator
wants when I wake in the morning yeah I
will put my hands wide apart yeah I
would look to heavens and I would say
thank you silently within me thank you
for my existence I would not say I would
not say anything else I would not pray
to him I would not ask him for anything
this type of prayer we say thank you no
no no no no no type of prayer that's
that's an acknowledgement of my
existence okay how do you know the
Creator wants you to do this for him to
him pardon how do you know how do you
know that the Creator want to I I you
see I never said that the Creator wanted
me to do it okay I said that I do it
because one I acknowledge the Creator
okay and I'm happy to exist and asking
you different question he's asking you
what make you sure to do this how do you
you know yourself that this is the right
way to to create to grateful to well I'm
not going to answer that cuz you can't
accept it know your answer we want I
said I would tell you because you cannot
accept it what I will tell you is this I
know there is a creator you understand
this is something that I know and I know
that and I acknowledge that Creator the
Gratitude being in here I will not pray
to the Creator I do not believe the
Creator wish anything from me I think
that all
that when you thank him that is a prayer
too that was an acknowledgement if
that's a prayer if that's a prayer then
that's a prayer I don't see it as a pray
I see it as I acknowledging the
existence of the Creator and that I'm
grateful to be here do you accept the
Creator as the most
wise these These are children that these
question that they are children do I
think they created most one do you
accept Okay the question that you should
ask me is this do you think do I think
the creature is good no no before that
just a second just a second dict I am
telling you the question that you should
ask no no no I'm asking you do you
accept the Creator as the most
wise I accept the Creator most
wise the most wise
Creator
without would you accept that the most
wise would create the Creation With a
Purpose do you think that the most wise
do I think the creat creat for a purpose
yes well I know what the purpose says
okay okay if you know your purpose and I
if your purpose is different than my
purpose how do know which purpose the
Creator create us for if you say my
purpose what is your purpose go ahead
what is your purpose my purpose yeah my
purpose is to draw and to evolve and the
only way that I can do that is from
experience you see step by step step by
step so the Creator created you for the
purpose for
you so if if for the sake for the sake
of so the cre cre creator with a purpose
so therefore who knows the purpose the
Creator as well yes but I just told you
that I just told you the Creator know
all the rest to know so how do you know
the purpose that Creator created you is
just for you to grow how do you did you
speak to the Creator that he told you
they created you for the pur just to
gr you're not ready for those answers
yeah I am ready I was you're not I was
born no you're not I am when you're
speaking to me and I can Mo it and I can
tell the level what you speak no no I
was Bor can you answer me I'll respect
Uncle pleas pardon can you answer me
Uncle please I'll respect how do you
know cuz you just accepted that the
Creator create us for a purpose so
therefore the Creator's purpose to me
and to you or to you is known how did
you know that the Creator created for
the purpose just for you to grow and
evolve
experience that that's not so if I
experience if someone says to you he
experience that he's the reason God
created him the purpose God created him
just to rape woman would you accept that
from
him well one one thing one say a cre I
don't think one would don't think it's
abusing the created cre no's I'm
not if we if we yes but you see you see
what we do is we have a way of judging
people we do not know we do not know for
example I was born when I was I knew
absolutely nothing that's right but in
spirit form I knew all there was to know
in spirit form you knew what in the
spirit form you see you probably see
yourself simply as Flesh and Blood no as
a soul I have a soul too we have a soul
we have a soul and we have a n what is
the soul how do you um that's a good
question Allah said in the
Quran the knowledge of it is with Allah
we don't know the the reality of the
Soul well the soul the soul is the
equivalent part of the Creator
equivalent part of the Creator where you
get that
from from Muhammed have respect you
can't smok because you
respect respect what you doing you just
speaking based upon what the isas
experience and experience is is not
objective it's subjective correct so
therefore you cannot establish to us
objectively what the creator creates us
for because you erience is something
which is subjective but you can you can
objectively objectively because Muhammad
tell you not that because Muhammad told
me because if Muhammad
Muhammad our messenger of Allah he never
came to people and he said God send me
that's it no he gave them tangible IR
rational Universal proofs why he's a
messenger of Allah why he was sent by
God the almighty one of the proof which
is a prophecy which is so powerful
everyone can see it one of the prophecy
in the Quran Allah said Allah will make
Islam spread even if disbeliever dislike
it we know now there is a huge war
against Islam especially on in the
western uh World on the mainstream media
there's a huge war against Islam but the
fastest growing religion on the face of
the earth is Islam even though we know
the Muslim countries are weak who's
doing the job Allah and Allah mentioned
in the Quran 1,400 years ago so how a
man that existed 1,400 years ago in the
middle of desert who couldn't read and
write and he had a few followers and his
followers they were scared for their
lives he was telling them that Islam the
religion that he came with it will go
around the world and will overpower
everything and that's what's happening
now and what happened in the past this
man cannot be normal
man okay what did you go said well I
agree with you
objective if that's what you except if
that's that's your version but that's
objective like the brother said well
whatever it is it's what you believe and
I respect what you believe it's not
about respect I don't have any beliefs
because belief has no Foundation no you
do have no beliefs don't have any
foundation Bel one minute one
minute in time to come change there s
have beliefs even in English language if
you go to English dictionary the term
belief sometimes is used for a lack of
of of certainty or knowledge but the
belief that the Muslims we use is based
upon knowledge and C so as a Muslim say
I believe mean I know and I'm certain
well then why don't you use the word I
know why don't you because I know there
no comb a combin certainty but when I
say I believe include knowledge and
certainty it does yes well when if you
if you were to say Vernon my name is
Vernon if you say Vernon I know this I
would consider it to be a certain thing
no sometimes you know something but
you're not certain like I know I left my
my my daughter at home but I am certain
she's still at home
you see I believe me I know and I'm
certain and I say to you have respect
you seem a nice person but what we say
leave experience of the Old Testament so
on what you have to understand no doubt
every part of your body has a purpose
know you has a purpose what I know what
I know is that we are conditioned to
believe we are locked into systems of
belief we we we we we we we that what do
you mean we condition to believe we
condition to believe what do you mean
for for example we just discussed your
Rel relig and we discuss the Christian
religion and there are things in the
Christian religion that you don't accept
you
don't say dict you cannot tell me that
we that you don't you're not aware that
we've always been Li to no no muslim
Islam is a Tru I mean there is some
Muslim schol R Mur is a Muslim did you
know that R Mur is no I know he's um
Jewish why you say that why Muslim why
you say
that Uncle come be honest man be sincere
because you know what we say to you look
Allah in the Quran mentioned he said
whoever wants to believe let him believe
and ever want to disel let him disel I'm
going to be 100 let let me be
100% let me okay go ah here when Allah
said said Allah said whoever wants to
believe let him believe whoever wants to
disbel let him disbelief here Allah not
encouraging disbelief here Allah mention
in the Quran if you disbel the come of
that because this believeing God and the
the prophet Muhammad and his and the
prophets and Messengers it boils down to
arrogance and the the destiny of the
Arrogant ones is the Hellfire forever so
save yourself before it's too late
either you're going to be in Paradise
Eternal you know or you're going to be
in the Hell Fire forever and Islam goes
along with the sounding that be grateful
to your creator and understand what the
Creator's purpose for us to create us
because he already told us through His
prophets and Messengers not through your
experience or my experience cuz you exp
expence as subjective and the the most
wise the most wise the most wise the
most wise he has a problem with the Old
[Music]
Testament don't
believe the
started whoever don't believe Allah he
hatte the Bible he said he hate the
Bible he want to defend the Bible you
said you old imagine he
are speaking a lie you are speaking a
lie hopefully I see you another
time this is the example of religion no
it's not religion example of
bad he's a great example of a mad man
he's he's religious he's
religious Muslim no one is shouting
screaming here come screaming like a you
are speaking a lie here you are speaking
Li you said Quran says this what you say
what I want what I want what I want to
know you said Allah
says what I what I want to know is why
you responding to him that's a good
thing because why sometimes you're giv
him power you're right% and I appreciate
what you just said thank you for
reminding me cuz I'm human being I
forget but the problem he's right next
to my air I can't take it I feel like a
motor bike you know but anyway why we
say to you
inshallah hopefully I will see you
another time inah were you from America
no I was born in the West Indies West
Indies about if you don't mind St
Vincent and then I went to barbad and
then I came here uh my wife is from St
Lucia St Lucia yes yeah I spent two days
there
terrified I heard some funny
stories